thank you Wuhan is back a street sign
signals the end of self-isolation
in a city where the corona virus
outbreak first submerged but body
temperature checks is strict and local
authorities urge people to avoid
gatherings
it's a city slowly coming back to life
restaurants have opened but only for
delivery not yet to sit him we were
severely affected by the two-month
closure jutsu coronavirus we are now
trying to compensate for the losses but
at the same time we take all
preventative measures people are once
again using public transport about 80%
of the city's workforce are returning
but locals are still concerned I am
still worried about the infection as the
virus first spread from Wuhan I dare not
use public transportation because I've
heard of infected cases but without
symptoms it's been two months since
people here were first told to self
isolate now they emerge from their homes
slowly and tentatively fears of a second
wave of infection of very much on
people's minds especially as many
infected people still don't show
symptoms of the disease
Laura Berta Manley al-jazeera